hey
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
in their lives
[Music]
and when he saw that that she opened the
line
he basically was in north africa
he traveled to honduras i think he was a
lawyer
he learned spanish from what i remember
for the sake of allah to do da'wah
then he's engaging with his daughter i
believe he's using his own finances to
invest in the dawah he's on his own kind
of thing he eventually gets married to
the
former vice president's daughter i think
she becomes muslim
to cut a long story short we engage with
him he becomes one of our outreach
specialists he's doing some amazing
phenomenal work
then we fund a center
it's the irs center in honduras and it
was opened by his father-in-law who was
the former vice president of the country
not just this he couldn't do juma other
because in july you have to have at
least three people right
so he can't do jummah so what is he
doing
giving dawah after some time the whole
place is full of muslims
new muslims yeah and many other stories
we have a story of brother i think his
name is abu bakr from the philippines we
have about nine outreach specialists in
the philippines now
he basically was running the semester
that the saudis built they built it and
they
left they run away so he's like what can
i do so he
the the masjid is next to the sea so he
puts like a lighthouse on the minaret to
help everybody right
he's doing good deeds helping his
brothers and sisters in islam and in
humanity
he sets up a radio station in the masjid
giving da
to everyone in the area lots of people
becoming muslim from what i formed they
were telling me
guess what happens i think some
christian groups send some mercenaries
to kill him
they go to kill him and they don't they
become muslim because of his
yeah you go all these amazing phenomenal
stories
in the tower honestly and and and this
is why
um it's all about empowering these
brothers and there's so many of them
all around the world take for example
salman sugimoto
and other outreach specialist of ours in
japan he basically tried
co-translate the quran in the popular
japanese language
because the language japanese has like
three levels or three
kind of this is formal japanese popular
japanese or something like that
there wasn't a quran in the popular type
of japanese language so
he translated that now who helps him to
free up his time
it's thou organizations that help them
and support them to do that amazing work
um what other amazing stories do we have
we have sister nancy from paraguay she
works for the government i think it's
some kind of like
home office thing or whatever she
basically was the
she changed paraguay law because
she had to have a passport with a hijab
on it and they changed the law i believe
in order for her to have a a hijab on
the passport
she knows the language of the indigenous
people she gives dau
to the indigenous people and indigenous
people you'd be so surprised
they have this old religion that sounds
very similar to islam
they do this test speed like 33 times
they praise god
they i think they do sajdah it's
phenomenal there's a book that you
should read it's called
the gospel of the red man it was when
the missionaries came over to
the latin america they started writing
accounts on the kind of indigenous
religion
from what i remember they used to
do wudu in a river they used to do
sajdah
they used to do they should believe in
one god and i believe they used to fast
as well
to show that you know these kind of
islamic things you know because we
believe that
tawheed was from the beginning right um
so there's some phenomenal stories and
we're covering a lot of the countries in
latin america and i do some really good
work we have a center in bolivia as well
um but here you need to come i want you
to come
you you love it you will love it i think
the studies are showing that
book reading is going up because people
had enough of using their phones you
can't do everything on your phone
it's very tiring yes
because i think it works
yeah my granddad's from north west
greece
yes which is 15 15 miles near albania
okay
yeah so my videos on the mountain yeah
yeah yeah
okay so we've got the same scenery yeah
chapter 41
verse 34 good and evil are not the same
repel by that which is better and if
there's hatred between two people it
would turn to intimate friendship
what's very interesting is allah doesn't
say repel evil
the arabic repel is not followed by a
direct object so it's
allah is trying to say to us repel
anything by that which is better and
what does
say they say that which is better is
that which is more beautiful
and that which is more ethical more
virtuous
but this is this is the crux of the
matter here
the verse before the verse before is
just
about down allah says in the quran
and who is better in speech than the one
who calls to allah
does righteous deeds and says i'm one of
the muslims and then allah says
good and evil are not the same and he
continues so
the characteristic of of of the art of
people who call to islam they must have
means forbearance you repel anything but
that which is better
it's a really good story bro so outside
the famous shopping center in london
there was his brother
and uh he was doing a dollar store a
lady comes up to him and spits on his
face
so what does he do he smiles he's
smiling he takes a tissue out he's still
smiling from what i understand
and he wipes his face and he gets
another tissue he gives it to her
because her own dribble was on her face
she goes away
after some time maybe days or weeks or
months she comes back
she becomes muslim and after some time
they get married so say to the sisters
if you want a good husband go on his
face first
but it shows look at the way he reacted
he reacted with
with patience with suburb with with
beauty with virtue
yeah and look what happens it opened
that woman's heart
we should do this more often no
absolutely spend a week in like
200 minutes